what is the furthest limit of the fossil
and tectonic record and what is known
about how much further that the earth
supported a stable crust and life I have
heard okay the earth has never had a
stable crust I look around whoa nope
it's churning daily that's why we don't
have quakes right go look look at the
USGS Earthquake page on the Internet and
it's a record of all the earthquakes in
the world
they're like hundreds a day every day
every day every day every day the only
ones you hear about are the ones that
shake and break a city but they're their
tremors their you know level two three
four and five New York City had one last
year for goodness sake okay not a big
enough to topple buildings but and that
was based in Virginia I think it was it
was very realized that's right the
energy was spread out so thinned out the
energy so that's why there was no real
disasters from that from that earthquake
so we've never had a stable crust a it's
still not stable it'll remain an
unstable for a long time to come be see
the earliest fossil evidence of life
goes back if you push it if you really
push it 3.7 3.8 billion years 20 billion
yeah these are single cells ee that's
correct
and before here's what happens if you
wait long enough the landmass that
you're on subduct
beneath other land masses and rejoins
the mantle and comes back out as a
volcano as lava so earth remakes its
surface over a several billion years so
that's why the oldest rocks on earth are
not as old as the oldest rocks on the
moon exactly because the moon was done
with its volcanic activity very early
right and once you're done you're wrong
you're not really making it is not
remaking yourself you're just sitting
there you're just sitting there but the
earth is kind of like our skin is that
what you're saying kind of like I guess
I you know if you're a metrosexual and
you get skin peels and things fine
that's not my first one Chuck green
Chuck it's not the father but yes
you're constantly remaking your outer
epidermis yes I love it that's where my
mind goes to my next chemical peel